hello and welcome to the interview
podcast
uh if you're joining back in thank you
for listening again
if this is your first time here my name
is blake wright
i am a furniture designer and builder
out of los angeles
and this is my podcast every week i talk
to
artists and intellectuals and just
people who generally interest me
and this week is no different today's
guest
is dr brian keating he's a cosmologist
out of uc san diego uh
he has got plenty of credentials to
vouch for he is the director of the
simon's observatory um he also worked on
the bicep and bicep2 telescopes
i believe he was a one of the creators
of those telescopes actually
he's also got a book out called losing
the nobel prize
and he does a podcast called into the
impossible for the arthur c clarke
foundation
brian and i had a really great
conversation today uh he was a little
short on time so i tried to just
throw as many questions out there as i
could and luckily enough for me
he is a great communicator and he had
some awesome
answers to the questions that i threw
out there so
uh yeah it was a great talk and i hope
to have him on again soon
if you're not familiar with uh brian
keating's
podcast into the impossible it's also on
youtube he
probably gets just as much traffic on
youtube seems like he kind of favors the
youtube videos for these but yeah if
you're not familiar you should
definitely check it out he's got
you know world-class theoretical
physicists and
astronomers and cosmologists and all the
like
uh as well as just great minds on the
show uh i've been following his podcast
for a little while now
and uh it was just a huge honor for me
to have him on this show
especially so young into the show and i
just want to thank him again for coming
on
and i really hope that you enjoy our
conversation if you could please
leave a like and review on my podcast
interview as well as subscribing on
itunes and spotify
i also have a youtube channel interview
pod
and i'm on instagram at interview pod
once again every monday i've got new
shows coming out
and if you like what you hear today then
i hope that you will subscribe
and um and there will be more coming
your way thanks again and enjoy the
episode
let's do it man awesome so am i all
right
welcome to the interview podcast my
guest today
is the professor of physics at the
center for astrophysics and space
sciences
at ucsd uh he's an author he's got a
book out called losing the nobel prize
and he also does a podcast called into
the impossible
for the arthur c clarke foundation uh
welcome to the show
brian keating how are you buddy uh it's
great to be with mr wright you know i
just hope my
my wife doesn't find out you exist i
tell i tell people you know
my friends that are single women that
they shouldn't look for
finding the perfect man because my wife
got the last one
oh yeah now i know mr wright so who
knows
exactly well
it's a really a pleasure to have you on
the show today i've been listening to
your podcast for a while and watching
you on youtube and uh
i'm definitely a fan so i really
appreciate you being here with me
i'm glad to be here with you it's a lot
of fun awesome
well um for people who aren't aware of
you i'm sure if they're watching this
they probably already are
but uh could you briefly describe um
you know a little bit about your career
maybe um about the
bicep telescopes that you worked on and
a little bit about what you're doing
nowadays
so yes so it's a pleasure to be here i
am
a cosmologist so i am
someone who works on hair nails makeup
no that's a cosmetologist but actually
they have the same prefix which is
cosmos
which means beauty and as you can see
behind me if you're watching on youtube
i get to work in some pretty beautiful
places and i get to look at the
beauty of the night sky and that's where
that prefix cosmos comes from
it's a beautiful universe and we have to
uncover it and nature gives us certain
abilities to do that
and my team and i build telescopes that
can peer back
to the very beginning of light to the
beginning
of the earliest light in the universe
when it set out on its journey
over 13.798 billion years
traveling through space and time
encountering all sorts of interesting
media on its way to our telescope so
behind me is pictured the atacama desert
of chile
and the site of the simon's observatory
which i am proud to be the
principal investigator of along with a
huge team of the most brilliant far more
brilliant than i am
uh scientists in the world and so we're
looking for the wispy afterglow of the
big bang
and that's called the cosmic microwave
background radiation
right and yeah go ahead and you're one
of the
premier researchers of the cmb as i'm
aware of
well yeah it is my specialty it's what
i've chosen to focus on
and my career has been dedicated to for
what's coming up on
you know 30 years almost now and in
addition to the
day job as a practicing cosmologist i
also
wrote a book as you said it's called
losing the nobel prize
it's uh now available in paperback
kindle and
audiobook and hardcover and it's the
story of what it
is like to be a young scientist striving
to accomplish the greatest feats
in his or her field and in my case
that's to
unravel the mysteries of how the
universe came to
came to be and along the way aspiring to
win the most prestigious award that
there is in all of society not just
science and that's
known as the nobel prize yeah i i read
your book
in preparation for this and it was a
pleasure
and a really good experience reading
that and it uh
taught me a lot of things that i
wouldn't have ever even thought to think
of
you know in the scientific fields just
kind of the politics around everything
it's just something that i think
ordinary people don't really think of
science
as political and uh it was interesting
to hear your take on that and
uh you know get some insight behind
these things that are so mysterious to
most people
uh what what interested you about the
cmb
and uh you know how did you get you
you mentioned that you kind of chose to
focus on that in your career
what about that interested you so much
that you chose to go down that path
yeah when i started uh as a graduate
student is when you
choose what your focus is going to be or
foci for some of us have multiple
interests
but it was always appealed to me what
always appealed to me were the
biggest topics that could possibly be
encountered
whether it be the origin of matter uh
the origin of space and time
or perhaps you know the existence of a
creator
or lack thereof and so i was always
fascinated by
questions which you know to many and
rightfully so are so daunting that most
people don't think about them
let alone choose to work in that field
but for me to understand
uh and have a sense of satisfaction with
a craft with a profession
really required that i slake my
intellectual thirst and that was to
understand the nature of physical
reality
as revealed through measurements and and
even the underlying mathematics behind
it
i can relate and you know pondering
those large questions i
obviously don't work in that field at
all but they uh
they definitely keep me up at night just
thinking about this yeah i could tell
from your guest
you talk to guests you know you come to
me as this humble uh
humble podcaster with a request in a
totally different field that i've ever
encountered a podcaster but then i
listened to your
listen to your past guest list and i see
that you have an insatiable curiosity
that extends beyond your field and
actually that for me is the hallmark so
i'm often asked well what's it like to
be a graduate student
and you know is it just non-stop work
there are all these jokes about you know
i even i make them that you know
graduate students work eight days a week
et cetera uh and it is extremely
grueling to go through and it's sort of
this
rite of passage that's been unchanged in
almost a thousand years since the first
phds were sort of granted in
bologna italy in the 18 in the first
millennium at the end of the first
millennium
but um you know in our field you have to
have passion
you must have curiosity otherwise you're
not going to make it through it's like
you cannot last
five six seven years as a student
pursuing something
uh if it's just like you're phoning it
in i mean first of all you're not making
that much money you do get paid to be a
graduate student in physics
and most places if you're getting a phd
but it's not much
it's you know below minimum wage
considering how many hours you work so
if you don't have passion if you don't
have drive
if you don't have initiative that i
always say only become a graduate
student
and study whatever field you you're in
um science or not
only become a graduate student if you
can't see not becoming a graduate
student otherwise
it's not going to be for you i can
relate to that you know pursuing
a career in an artistic field where you
know i'm making furniture i'm doing
woodworking and metalworking and
um i'm not making money i'm spending a
lot more than i'm making on
materials and workshop and everything
sounds like my podcast
yeah but you know it's i'm in it more
for the gratification of
the making and you know the process and
the artistic creation and
the learning is really the main thing
that drives me has always
just been gaining more knowledge uh
which i'm sure yeah relate to yeah it's
absolutely correct and
and in fact you know sometimes people
come to me and they want to be a
graduate student and i say
did you ever work on your car you know
did you ever you know tweak her and now
it's harder to do that you know if their
car is a
you know a monitor tesla or something
like that in fact uh i think yeah i
think
i don't want them if they're working on
you know their tesla
but instead you know i think about it as
uh
kind of things i used to have in 1979 uh
you know volkswagen rabbit
that actually had uh you know probably
cost far less than my podcast equipment
cost today
but i had an insatiable desire because i
had
no i had a satiable wallet you know i
had very little money
i was working my way through high school
and college and uh
i wanted to fix the brakes i wanted to
put in a you know a
kick-ass stereo system i couldn't do it
i couldn't take it to a store
to do it so i had to do it myself and uh
but that really
um taught me what the value of of manual
labor is and and that came in extremely
valuable
um you know oftentimes at the site
pictured behind me we're at almost eight
seventeen thousand feet above sea level
and you have a problem with the diesel
generator well what is a diesel
generator it's the same as an engine
in a car yeah and and you have to tweak
it and fix it and understand why is it
not firing up why does it need you know
what kind of property well i had that
same problem
in 1988 with my rabbit
and now i can you know tweak it so you
talked about the book about
working at the south pole and just
the remoteness of that location i'm sure
it's the same in chile there but
i'm sure you've got to get pretty
ingenuitive when you're working so
remotely
oh yeah yeah the south pole and see if i
can find a picture to replace my
virtual background right now but i'll
show you a picture of the south pole
it is indeed a very uh place unlike any
other place on earth so right behind me
is my experiment there there's bicep on
the right above my shoulder there and
there's another telescope on the far
left called the south pole telescope
but behind me you see almost nothing
it's basically flat
barren white you know frozen frigid
plateau there's nothing there here's the
here's the building that we live in this
is where our dorms are and each one
i can touch both sides of the wall
simultaneously
it's not a place you go for you know a
great deal of wide open spaces but there
are beautiful things there here's a
picture of friends launching a
stratospheric balloon near an active
volcano
uh called mount erebus at the uh
antarctic station and here's how we get
there on a
military cargo plane paid for by your
tax dollars uh
the u.s air force so uh it's an amazing
place to be it's incredibly remote
it's dangerous it has uh very forbidding
aspects to it but you know the payoff of
doing the science really makes it all
worth it
yeah there's something beautiful about
that too you're so out there and you're
you're peering into deep space and it
almost seems like you're not on earth
and there's there's something beautiful
there absolutely yeah we actually have
at the south pole you'll be interested
to know
there's carpenters there's plumbers
there's electricians you can't make all
this stuff behind me look at this this
building behind me
right next to my ear on the left side of
the screen
that's a huge gigantic wooden building
and that's a dorm where we stay
while we wait for our plane and the
weather to improve to get us to the
south pole
and you meet all sorts of people here
it's like a mining town right and you
wouldn't think of it as primarily
dedicated to science but that's why it's
there and that's why we go there it's
one of the best places on earth to do
the science we need to do
why is it that that's the best place
there so
um i don't know where where you are
currently where are you located
i'm down in italy oh you're in l.a okay
i was going to say
um you know i come from the northeast
and sometimes in the northeast
you'll find uh on the weather report
which you never got growing up in l.a
but they would say things on the east
coast it was a snow day
and then some days it would be even
worse they'd say it's not a snow day and
you'd be like oh man why is it a snow
day
and the reason was it was too cold to
snow
so there was so much uh so little
moisture in the atmosphere it had all
here we are
at this picture behind me we're at 17
200 feet
above sea level the temperature is
negative 30 degrees
it's plenty cold enough for ice and snow
to form but the
any moisture in the air comes out of the
air leaving the sky
mostly pristine blue and and free of
clouds
uh and the south pole is even more uh
likely to be like that we here's a
here's a shot of mount uh
mount palomar here in san diego what
we're looking for
are these pristine blue skies and
actually you get a much higher chance of
that in a cold climate at high altitude
that's why telescopes are built up on
top of mountains
it's a little known fact the south pole
is built
up on a mountain not really a mountain a
plateau of ice it's totally flat there's
no
there's no terrain there's no features
at the south pole so i'm sure
here it is now you can look off in the
distance 800 kilometers
before you hit a mountain or see uh see
another living creature
but the sky is just this pristine dark
blue of space
and it's as close as you can get the
space we call it kind of the poor
scientist satellite
yeah 14 000 feet that's pretty
impressive so yeah that's the flat plain
yeah the south pole is about 9500 feet
and chile is at 17 000 feet
wow um so i know you're pretty short on
time today let's get into
some technical uh speak here can you
explain to us what the cmb is and why
it's so important to you
yeah the scenario is the oldest fossil
light
in the universe it's a type of light
that comes in all directions
it comes at all times of year in all
locations on earth
and it's basically the wallpaper of the
universe it's
light that's been traveling since the
formation of the first atoms
since the formation of hydrogen atoms
and since that time 13.8 billion years
ago
these uh particles of light called
photons by albert einstein
have been streaming towards our
telescopes on earth and throughout the
universe in fact
for those many millennia and by the time
they reach our telescopes they have
the imprints upon them of every physical
entity every quantity that they have
encountered
along the way from the telescope to our
our
uh from from the origin of of hydrogen
to our telescope so we're really in this
tradition of the great galileo galilei
i'm showing him uh first telescopes that
he used at his museum in
in florence italy uh dedicated to
galileo
and what we're trying to do is unravel
the nature of
all the effects all the physical
properties everything that's happened in
the universe
since the formation of the first atoms
and that's what we're trying to do
that's a noble pursuit that's um
pursuit yeah a lot of information there
to
try and solve from some photons yeah
there what's
interesting about nature is that it
gives you precious little information
even if you're on earth but at least if
you're on earth you could do an
experiment you probably took in high
school or college or whatever
biology class you take a worm you cut it
open
you do something to the worm or you give
it some you do an experiment on it and
you compare it to another worm
uh that you didn't do these dastardly
deeds to
and then you see what are the effects of
the uh of what you did
on the worm compared to the control worm
that you didn't touch
and that process is is a process of you
know multiple testing multiple specimens
etc
how do you do that when you have only
one universe to study
it's very hard and how do you do it when
you
yeah i can't go out and change the
temperature of the sun
by 10 and then ask well what happens to
the production of
uh this element uh you know or this this
molecule called
phosphine that was discovered on venus
what would it look like if the sun were
10 hotter oh let me just do that
experiment no you can't do it
so all we have to do all we have to work
with are
particles of light and particles of
matter that come from the
universe itself and we just have to be
patient but
encoded within those particles as a vast
amount of information
but you have to be clever you have to
have a good uh team you have to have
good technology
and you most of all have to be patient
these things have been traveling 14
billion years
yeah you better spend your time with
them
i saw on your last slide there and also
it was a major theme in your book the b
mode signals that you're searching for
what exactly are these b mode signals
so if whenever matter is
uh is impacted by light so here's an
image
of sunlight on the left coming from the
sun bouncing off the ocean here in los
angeles san diego whatever and then
being reflected to an observer wearing
glasses in this case they're polarized
sunglasses whenever light interacts with
matter as i'm showing here
uh let me just cover up my face you
don't need to see me but
whenever light interacts with matter it
induces
the possibility for it to become
polarized which means
that the light will have a preferential
axis at which it is
oscillating about that's called the
polarization direction
most people are familiar with two
properties of light its color
and how bright it is but there's a third
property called polarization
which says which direction the electrons
in the electromagnetic field would be
oscillating if the light hit it
and most light is unpolarized from
sources like the sun and stars
but when it interacts with matter in
this case water
it has a propensity to become polarized
so you can use that to either the
the net polarization that you observe in
your polarized sunglasses here
you can use that to either learn about
the source of light
namely the sun or learn about the
properties of the matter that it
interacted with namely the ocean
and as long as the matter has some um
some symmetries that are broken within
it
namely it has waves or it has patterns
it has change in density or salinity or
whatever
you will get a different type of
polarization signal depending on the
properties of the matter
in our case with these b modes what
we're studying
is not the matter itself we know that
there was matter in the early universe i
said there was hydrogen
and right before hydrogen formed the
universe also had
a great deal of photons but in addition
to the matter
it had space and time and einstein
predicted in 1915 was that space
time itself could be
could be perturbed it could have tiny uh
variations from point to point in space
namely that you would weigh a little bit
more
your body would weigh physically more in
one location
either depending on the proximity to a
source of gravitational waves or
depending on how long you wait after a
certain event
called uh called the big bang in this
case so what we're looking for
is this interaction of matter and light
caused by these ripples of space and
time called gravitational waves
and they would produce we were told we
were hoping
uh literally they would produce this
pattern called b mode polarization that
i'm showing here
and in fact we claim that we did see it
using the bicep 2 telescope
located here in the center of this image
and i'm showing here the bicep 2
telescope
at the south pole which i have designed
with my colleagues at caltech
to detect exactly the signal as we
hoped that we would be able to reveal
the earliest
uh the earliest traces of matter and
energy in the universe's history
wow that's a it's quite an explanation
there
so if i'm understanding this correctly
the b mode signals are
um basically the polar polarization of
the photons that have interacted with
the matter
on the way to the telescope yeah so
anything can cause polarization
as long as there is light and as long as
there is matter
you can have the prop the the the
possibility of polarization occurring
uh but that same pattern that i'm
showing here which we knew would lead to
nobel
gold had we detected it can also be
produced by
other effects besides gravitational
waves
that these b modes can come from sources
that are
basically nuisance effects that we don't
want to see
in the case of what ended up being the
culprit in the bicep two
episode uh there were these tiny grains
of dust
produced in the same cataclysmic uh
nuclear
explosions called supernovae that most
likely formed
the uh heavy elements in our body namely
the calcium silicon
uh nitrogen and even the iron in the
hemoglobin molecule that flows through
our veins
so there's iron in there and that comes
from a supernova that exploded perhaps
five
six billion years ago in our galaxy
and uh and and created the material in
which the sun
and the planets were formed in our solar
system but also polluted the
interstellar medium between the stars in
our galaxy
with dust and that dust can get aligned
with the milky way as a magnetic field
just like the earth has a magnetic field
and that milky way's alignment can
produce a pattern of microwaves that
will have the same kind of swirling
twisting patterns that we claimed and we
did detect
so in fact what we saw and we later
realized was not the
imprint of inflation the the aftermedia
aftermath
of the of the origin of space-time
itself
but rather these tiny little grains of
dust spinning in magnetic fields
that thread their way throughout the
milky way galaxy
while you're on the subject of
supernovae i'd like to talk
about black holes a little bit sure um i
read this morning
in quantum magazine uh a very
interesting
article and i'd like to read you a
little quote from that article
and see what your thoughts are on it it
says
let's see here in some way or another
space-time itself seems to fall apart at
a black hole implying that space-time is
not the root level of reality
but an emergent structure from something
deeper although einstein conceived of
gravity as a
geometry of space-time his theory also
entails the disillusion of space-time
which is ultimately why information can
escape its gravitational prison
so the article was about how they're
theorizing that
information can escape a black hole um
is this something
that you've given thought to is it
something that you
are working on what is your take on this
it's not something
i've either you know uh worked on or
given thought to i will say that um
my friend sir roger penrose just won the
nobel prize
uh and will receive it in a couple of
weeks he's been on my podcast multiple
times and he's going to come back he
said
which is great and he's worked on
exactly this topic
of black holes and their properties
really revealing
the strange and beautiful structures
that they
sort of possess one of the things that
he worked on with his very close friend
and colleague stephen hawking
was the notion that black holes are sort
of these cosmic vacuum cleaners
that uh have a peculiar property that
when you put matter inside of them they
they grow in a certain way and that
their area increases
their surface area increases by some
amount and that depends on the material
that you throw in
so the more bits of information the more
molecules that you
throw in you can increase the size of it
and in a sense the information that you
throw on is fungible
in that if i throw in my phd thesis or
losing the nobel prize
it could be the same as just throwing in
a lump of paper or the same amount
and all that comes out is the black hole
gets a little bit bigger
now the question of how black holes
eventually evaporate
and can radiate via a process called a
hawking radiation that
is a predicted effect by stephen hawking
to occur over you know
literally billions if not trillions of
years for some black holes
and these black holes then would radiate
the information
out and they would disappear and in that
sense
you there's a question about how the
entropy or the information properties of
the black hole
might get uh taken away in other words
you might decrease the entropy of the
system when considering
the uh the the system of the black hole
before
and after within the universe so it's
not something i work on
although uh sir roger penrose has a
theory
that some of the data that i'm showing
here the swirling twisting pattern of
microwaves known as b modes
from the bicep 2 experiment he claims
that they are actually
remnants of black holes in a preceding
eon he calls it oh yes
i heard him discuss this i believe last
time he was on your show actually yeah
that's right so that's called hawking
points and he believes they come from
black holes that
survive the transition from one eon
a-e-o-n in his nomenclature to the next
and so he's agreed now he's gotten a lot
of publicity from winning the nobel
prize obviously
right although he endorsed my book
entitled losing the nobel prize and
called it a wonderful book
so i pointed that out to him uh so
hopefully he'll come on my show and i
can ask him
that very question that you're posing
about this notion of of
information and the so-called
information paradox of black holes i
also have on uh lenny suskind
who wrote a book called black hole wars
it's my battle with stephen hawking over
black holes so he's going to come on in
a couple weeks
get some differing opinions there uh
yeah i mean the
the line that sticks out to me most from
that article is
that they're saying that maybe space
time is not the root level of reality
but there could be
some kind of you know source code behind
space-time
uh is that something that you would
agree with do you think it's
maybe possible some kind of no i i don't
subscribe to that kind of that's a
little more far out from
it's pretty deep yeah i always find it
funny that people talk about the source
code or the simulation hypothesis
i'm hoping to have nick balstrom on the
podcast he wrote
a wonderful book about effectively the
simulation hypothesis that we're
actually running in a computer
simulation
but i always point out anything with a
source code or simulation implies a
simulator
which implies some teleological purpose
perhaps which is tantamount
in my mind to maybe a creator if you're
so inclined or if even if you're not
most most scientists most cosmologists
90
probably are atheists like devout
atheist
but yet they entertain things like the
simulation hypothesis not all but some
do
and uh i always find it a little bit
ironic that they um
they'll promote things that have
encrypted within them uh
you know a three-year-old uh ethical
uh morality um with with perhaps
monotheism encoded
but they don't ever study the 3 000 year
old
ethical monotheistic tradition of the
western hemisphere
yeah i mean in this particular article
they weren't necessarily
hinting it at anything like that i think
what they were mostly talking about was
string theory um
they were wondering if you know things
can escape a black hole through strings
and uh they were also talking about uh
entanglement between the
the outer surface and the inner side of
the black hole yeah
yeah those are those are topics that you
know certainly i think about
and um i'm curious about i did a series
of episodes this summer
uh with people ranging from stephen
wolfram uh
to eric weinstein there's mathematica
logo behind me here
and uh we did a bunch of episodes
concerning those
uh new theories that eric weinstein and
and
stephen wolfram have in particular other
people garrett leacy
and there's a proliferation of these
theories including you know
theories of everything based on uh
effective field theory as it's called
and
more standard things related to quantum
gravity via string theory and super
symmetry i've had on jim gates
uh who professor jim gates uh who's very
involved in this
so i always um you know i'm curious
about these things
but i always uh get a little concerned
when people get a little too
woo-woo about you know perhaps they're
being you know this uh
cosmic uh what i won't say
who but one of my friends has you know
this cosmic
uh like i don't know macrame or some
kind of weird uh
weird patterns uh mandela's and and and
things like that that
i don't uh have much uh confidence in
their reality thereof
i could see how it's easy to go there if
you're too uh too consumed by the
subject
yeah that's so mysterious it is mystery
look at this i mean the mystery of the
night sky to me is enough
in mind to understand uh when you're
looking for
you know these these relic remnants of
fossils traveling through time for 14
billion years it's like
uh you don't need to add on anything to
that it's like when people say i want to
make um
i'll say like uh holding hands with my
wife
i want to make that more exciting like
uh let's put on special gloves and no no
it doesn't need that like it's it
it's already pretty damn good the way
that nature god if you will
planned it um what are your thoughts on
universal limits
things like you know the speed of light
and absolute zero
why do you think they exist yeah i've
heard you talk about things like the
plank length
and expansion of the universe and things
like that is it um also
do you think it's just something that
we're kind of making
or do you think they really do exist oh
definitely yeah there are things that
that are clearly made up by the human
mind
i i forget who it was it might have been
polly wolfgang paulie
who sort of had this mystical side to
him i did a podcast with paul halpern
about paulie's friendship with
carl young and others um and paulie was
an amazing
physicist came up with the poway
exclusion principle the concept of the
neutrino
and and yet he believed in you know kind
of um
different kinds of of psychological
theory that we you know dream
interpretation and stuff that we believe
is total hocus pocus um but uh another
physicist
you know looked at uh one particular
constant called the fine structure
constant
and that governs the strength of
electromagnetism and it's comprised
merely of the electric charge constant
and coulombs
uh planck's constant and the speed of
light and
by suitable arrangement you can get a
dimensionless constant in other words
it's a number
of taking just those things and putting
them in a certain pattern
and that number when divided into one
has the value 137
exactly or so they thought back in the
30s or so and
so somebody's so a lot of really earnest
physicists we're looking for
you know kind of numerological reasons
what is 137
a prime number it's composed of these
perfect squares
and then it turns out no it's not 137
it's 137.05 two
seven nine of them you know whatever has
no
round uh natural number significance
whatsoever
and so but you don't hear those people
say i was wrong it's just like oh well
maybe we have to add on pi
the square root to the ninth negative
ninth power you know
so i find those things more a pattern of
confirmation bias like richard feynman
who is at caltech not far from you
uh way back in the 60s he came into
lecture one day he said
you're not going to believe what i saw i
saw a license plate and it had the
following
uh had the following license plate tag
number it had
n6t qr5 oh my god that's amazing you
know what the probability is of finding
that light
and everyone's like what the heck and
it's like just totally random but
people will see a pattern and want to
attribute something to it and i think
that's the numerological kind of
conceit that the human mind seeks thanks
to its desire for confirmation
and that confirmation bias that can
result yeah and that confirmation bias
is um
obviously it's always an issue in
science but uh particularly we're
talking about theories of everything
it seems like that is something that
plagues people when they're searching
for theories of everything
is you know connecting these dots that
aren't necessarily supposed to connect
yeah that's right well you try to force
something that wasn't there but
you know as i pointed out in my book the
greatest scientist in history
uh ranging from albert einstein more
recently to my hero
galileo galilei back in the
you know in the 17th century they were
looking to prove effects you know
i i mentioned to people there's a famous
book by galileo called the dialogue
have you ever heard of it yeah so it's
this uh second to last book it's called
the dialogue on two world systems
where galileo was outlining his
arguments for copernicanism the theory
that the earth
is not the center of the universe but
the sun is and his claim
was copernicus's claim that the earth
orbits around the sun
well uh galileo wanted nothing more than
to prove this to be the case it's
actually what led him to be
imprisoned house in prison right he was
never tortured or anything as i talk
about but he
he was in prison and uh here's the
prison that he was in by the way this is
pretty brutal i i don't know if your
audience has young people please turn
away from the screen this is the
horrible prison
that galileo was forced to be in let me
cover up my face there i am there
so this is this beautiful villa that's
called villa galileo
in outside of florence on a hill that
overlooks the duomo in italy it's
unbelievable it's paradise i had a
conference there the worst thing that
happened to me is i hit my head on the
doorway because the doorway is only five
foot five inches tall and i'm a little
taller than that
um so you know this this notion that
galileo was tortured imprisoned
etc is really uh a fantasy and it's kind
of a malicious rumor
but in reality here's one of the views
from his palace
and it was near his daughter who is a
nun at a convent not far from there
anyway less in prison more confined yeah
exactly yeah
and that's and he even wrote more books
after he was in prison so i was like i
always say you know bernie madoff would
kill to have a prison
cell that nice uh literally so
getting back to galileo he felt that the
best
uh the best proof that the earth was
going around the sun
was the behavior of the earth's tides
you know here now
in san diego la we notice there are four
tides a day two high tides two low tides
and galileo said that yes that's right
that proves
copernicus was right because that
happens after going through
significant discussion because the earth
is rotating on its axis
and it's revolving around the sun so
it's moving these two compound rotations
and here's my irish coffee down there
and you see how the irish coffee gets
shaken up right well that
is the reason we have tides on earth
according to galileo proving the earth
rotates and it revolves
there's one problem that's totally wrong
the earth's tides are not caused by
either any of the aspects of galileo's
uh attributed to
in fact it's caused by the moon but
what's so interesting is that book the
dialogue
which is a beautiful title the dialogue
on the two systems of the universe
effectively
the original title that galileo wanted
was
on the flux and reflux of the earth's
tides in rivers
and ferns what the hell's a fern but
anyway um
i had to look that up but the point is
uh he was driven
through confirmation bias perhaps to
even ruin the
brilliance ideas of his own book and in
fact it was the pope who effectively
caused him
to change the title to the dialogue
which is a much more striking
title than the annals of scientific
history that's crazy i mean that
that must have been quite a trip for you
you know visiting
i i know that you visited galilee's home
and you saw
obviously his prison there that you were
talking about what did you gain from
that trip
do you think you gained any kind of
insight into who he was
yeah it's it's an amazing place i hope
everyone can get to visit there and soon
i hope coved dissipates soon
um you know just being there in the
presence of this great man
you know and and seeing there's the
front door to the house
and just being in this august
environment
is impossible not to feel his spirit and
to see these trees on the path
to his house and some of them are you
know he was picking the olives from
uh it's it's an amazing experience to
have that you can't often do that
uh you know go to some place where you
know jesus was and and
you know you can but but the point is
that those are magical special places
uh that are more or less intact for for
literally centuries and for someone like
me
who worshipped galileo as a kid and
still does to be honest with you
uh because he's such an example of a of
a deep person
uh with brilliant ideas and and horrible
fallacies
and and failings and biases and
prejudices and guess what
you know let the as jesus say you know
let he without sin
cast the first stone and uh if
before you complain about the about the
moat of dust in your neighbor's eye take
out the plank of wood in your own eye
so uh a lot of a lot of uh quotes from
jesus from this uh jewish scientist over
here i'm sorry
that's all right he was a jewish
carpenter
yeah exactly uh let's get back into the
science of things
um so when you're looking at the cmb
are you able to
find hints of what lies beyond the cmb
and do you think there is anything else
beyond the cmb
yeah there certainly has to be something
beyond the stand b
for the cmb is only formed once the
universe cooled sufficiently after some
process we don't know exactly what but
it cooled below
a certain temperature and that
temperature
was small enough that hydrogen could
form
so there was certainly something that
existed before
hydrogen formed and that was the protons
neutrons
crew now the protons neutrons electrons
and light
that make up uh the cosmic microwave
background hydrogen and the subsequent
generations of stars planets people
podcasters that came afterwards so the
question is
can we use a technology to get behind it
uh beyond it and the answer is yes
uh if uh there was a source of
information other than light
for technical reasons we can't see
through the cmb
using light because it is the first
light in a sense
but there doesn't mean there aren't
other things beyond it like neutrinos or
gravitational waves and in fact that's
what we're trying to do we're trying to
see if there are gravitational waves
which can go through matter the same way
that a gravitational wave can go through
the whole earth or the moon's gravity
goes through both sides of the earth at
the same time producing
a high tide on one side of the earth and
a high tide exactly on the opposite side
of the earth at the same time
so gravity goes through matter and it
can go through the cmb as well
and it can imprint the cmb with a
particular type of pattern
that we call this b mode polarization
but that's only if
gravitational waves exist prior to
the formation of the cmb we know they
exist today
because we detect them or my colleagues
detect them using ligo and other
gravitational wave instruments so we
know they're real
we know that they exist after the cmb
was formed but do they exist beforehand
that's the you know that's the uh one
million
or whatever three million kroner uh
question that
for whoever is successful if it exists
we'll certainly
not lose this prize as spoiler alert i
myself
did yeah and that goes back to uh
penrose's theory about this kind of
cyclical universe and
maybe gravitational waves or black hole
whatever being able to traverse
through from one aeon to the next yeah
that's right we don't know
uh what the nature of the universe would
be like if the universe is not suffused
with
with the sort of picture that we talked
about namely that there was a big bang
and the and the force or the field that
ignited the big bang we call the
inflitan or the inflation
field but inflation's not necessarily
guaranteed to be right
if it were i wouldn't be doing research
i would be doing reading
and a lot of information a lot of work
goes into trying to unravel the nature
of inflation
but we're not 100 sure that it even took
place so
what we like to do in science is not try
to prove things we try to
disprove alternatives and that's sort of
what galileo did
in the dialogue he disproved the
ptolemaic or aristotelian
theory of geocentrism and he didn't
prove
that heliocentrism was correct he
couldn't do that back then we now know
it's correct
but sometimes this confirmation may not
be possible in our own lifetime
as it wasn't for galileo right right uh
what can you tell us about
the cold spot in the cmb yeah so it's
behind me in this picture down
here highlighted there on the right side
of the screen
so a good friend of mine named janet
levin and another good friend of mine
glenn starkman and david spurgle have
worked on problems
revolving around the anisotropy or the
the broken symmetry between the cmb
and as a function of where you look on
the sky this is exaggerated
but there seems to be some anisotropy
other than the ordinary fluctuations
and different from the galaxy that's
shown here that bright orange
is the milky way galaxy it produces
copious amounts of microwaves
thanks in large part to the dust that
befuddled our experiment
we did our experiment low down on this
image away from the plane of the galaxy
thinking that as in decades past there
wouldn't be a problem
but in the cold spot region uh there
actually
is a preponderance an excess of of
colder photons compared to hotter
photons
and uh it seems to be that there is some
alignment or some
very improbable alignment between these
and so
my friends jenna levin and glenn
starkman both of whom i've had on the
podcast
they speak about the improbability of it
and maybe some mechanisms to resolve it
and i think one of the most promising
ways to get further information
is we only know it's a cold spot thanks
to measurements of the
microwave background's temperature but
what we'd like to do is kind of verify
that it's real that it's not a
foreground
and it's not some kind of artifact in
the processing right
via using its polarization and to do
that you really need a very
good polarimeter working in the northern
hemisphere and the southern hemisphere
so bicep
simon's observatory they operate in the
southern hemisphere but i do
have colleagues that are building an
experiment in in china
called the ali cpt experiment
and they hope to have great statistical
constraining power
in the northern hemisphere and then the
hope is we compare data sets and see if
there is this
effect but it's something we're going to
target with the simon's observatory
absolutely
awesome how how large is that spot in
relation to
you know actual length oh it's millions
of
megaparsecs long it's one of the biggest
structures you know if it is indeed
a structure um you know a magnetic
monopole a void
yeah if it's if it's uh you know it's
comparable it's much much larger
than any galaxy cluster that we've ever
seen so
those can be tens to you know 100
megaparsecs across
meaning 100 300 roughly million light
years across
but that's pretty small compared to the
size of the universe which is now 90
billion
light years across but still it's uh
it's not it's not a
drop in the bucket it's something to be
investigated because it does stand out
like a
cold sore thumb when you say the
universe is 90 billion
light years across do you mean that
we've observed is the
universe not infinite so from any
perspective within the universe
any direction we look we can see back to
the beginning of
time or light itself when that light set
off 380 000 years after the formation of
the elements the
period of time we call the big bang uh
when you look when you take that that's
14 billion years
for simplicity call it call it uh 15
billion years
for the just making the math easier uh
it turns out that the universe
so that's how far away something would
be uh if the universe were basically
static in other words if the universe
had a diameter
at its birth which was 14 billion uh
light years 15 billion light years
but because everything in the universe
has been expanding
uh by and if you integrate the amount of
expansion that's occurred
since the cmb was formed you get a
factor of 3
in every dimension in other words the
actual radius
of uh how far we can see is not the
light travel time
times the speed of light it's the light
travel time times the speed of light
times the amount that the universe has
expanded
since this image was taken and going
through the math it turns out that the
radius the farthest we can see
out from our vantage point in the
universe is about
uh is about 45 billion light years
so it's three times the naive estimate
and then we can see out that far
say looking in the north direction if we
look down in the south direction we can
see something that's 45 billion light
years away
that means the two places that we're
looking at have a diameter of 90 billion
light years
wow that's uh that's awesome
that's so cool to hear you explain that
yeah it's uh it's the mind-bending
mystery so
oh yeah so blake we're gonna have to do
another uh part sometime i've got a
couple of kids that are aching to get
out of the house on this beautiful
beautiful day but i i certainly had a
great time on the show
and uh i can't wait till it comes out
yeah it was a pleasure talking to you
i've been looking for this
for a while now and uh i'll look forward
to your your next
uh episode with roger penrose as well
yeah that's coming soon and uh people
want to find me they can tune into the
into the impossible podcast i get all
sorts of guests
like here is my friend peter diamandis
episode 45
and i also have a so that's you can find
on itunes or wherever you get
when you're not listening to blake's
inner view podcast
listen to that and also my book um
losing the nobel prize a story of
cosmology
uh uh ambition and sciences perils of
science's highest honors and
find me on youtube at dr brian keating
and same address on twitter
absolutely i can vouch for it it's a
good read and a great youtube channel
thank you so much flag i hope you have a
great weekend you too
thanks again okay bye bye
[Music]